hi Mia I recently talked with a
developer who said they no longer needed
an operations team hi Martin why do they
think that
they outsourced the infrastructure to
Google by going serverless
well they might not need to replace hard
drives anymore but they still need a
team that can focus on operational
concerns oh uh what should they do then
well instead of getting rid of their
operations team they could adopt a new
model now they can work on more
interesting aspects of infrastructure
and operations like applying software
engineering to build automation that's
called site reliability engineering
[Music]
user decide to rely built engineering
might be a good way to operate instead
uh what is that site reliability
engineering or SRE is what you get when
you apply software engineering Concepts
to infrastructure and operations it was
born in 2003 out of Google's need to
operate reliable systems at scale okay
that sounds useful definitely and there
are other related movements throughout
the industry like devops and production
engineering but in my experience SRE
works really well so MIA in one of your
previous roles before Google you did SRE
work is that right yeah I've been on
call for production systems with
millions of registered users and I've
seen how things can go wrong I bet
Millions uh that's some serious scale
right there definitely and when you get
to that scale you have to start reducing
Toil and adopt something like SRE if you
want to keep up all right so you said
going serverless does not mean you can
skip operations work right you still
need some sort of operations team but
you can be smarter about operations and
adopt something like SRE the goal is
less toil and more interesting work at
this higher level of abstraction and
what do you mean by toil so toil is work
that's manual repetitive and most
importantly automatable an example of
toil might be maintaining Hardware in an
on-prem environment like using
monitoring graphs to keep an eye on hard
drive failures all right sitting and
watching graphs all day sounds
inefficient yeah and you could find ways
to automate your hard drive management
on-prem but Cloud providers have this
down to a science and it's often cheaper
to pay them to do it Outsourcing this
aspect of your stack helps eliminate
this toil wait so if Engineers no longer
have to spend their time monitoring
Hardware what will they spend their time
on they can start by focusing on app
level monitoring and Automation and
while this is a higher level of
abstraction than most Engineers are
probably used to working with it allows
for more impact and they can be more
proactive instead of constantly fighting
fires further down the stack all right
let's break that down Mia the first app
level monitoring is that different from
regular old monitoring yes and no so
measuring CPU load on your servers is an
example of pretty standard monitoring
however once you've gone serverless that
metrics less interesting because Google
will horizontally scale for you and that
frees up time to focus on metrics that
matter to your users like response times
yep I could see how business folks would
be more interested in response times
than in CPU load right it's easier to
work together on higher level metrics a
business person won't know if 70 CPU
load is good or bad but they will know
that a 0.1 second response time is good
right right these high level metrics
sound more useful yeah and compared to
Resource usage getting information from
within the application like traces and
query latency helps you better
understand what users are actually
experiencing okay that makes sense so
circling back to what you said before
automation was the other thing what what
would that look like
so maybe it takes a lot of manual work
to run through the testing and release
process if you automate that you'll end
up shipping your code faster and with
better quality and if you don't have to
monitor the lower layers of the stack
all the time you'll have time to look
into points of operational friction I
like that so do I automation of common
tasks means that you can scale your
operations as traffic grows this doesn't
mean that you don't need sres at all but
rather the people who already support
systems can be much more efficient so
SRE can scale sublinearly as traffic
grows okay so let's say an organization
switch from on-prem machine to
serverless Computing in Google Cloud
what aspects of operations work would
change well when you run an on-prem
system you manage all parts of the
system from networking all the way up to
the application yes and we did that at
the startups I worked at years ago let
me tell you Mia that was a lot of work
yeah it really is many teams want to
offload some of that work to a cloud
provider so they can scale the team
better instead of running it themselves
they just rent the networking and
compute that they need often called
infrastructure as a service or iaas the
end result is that you don't have to
worry about anything below the
virtualization of the machine and why
would a large cloud provider be able to
handle this virtualization server
storage networking all that stuff better
than the customer themselves
Cloud providers like Google operate at
scale and can buy and operate Hardware
in a very cost efficient way because of
this they can pass some of those savings
onto the consumer years of experience
designing and running infrastructure
means they can provide reliable and
resilient service
got it so if you pick infrastructure as
a service your cloud provider handles
everything from virtualization on down
but I've heard of many customers who
don't want to manage the operating
system for example
right and then you go with platform as a
service or paas Ah that's where I want
to be that's serverless Computing right
yeah that's serverless and many
organizations prefer to go serverless
because it leaves fewer things for them
to manage ah fewer things to manage
that's good should everyone go
serverless for many teams serverless
works very well I should mention that
some organizations have regulatory
requirements that prevent them from
going serverless others might have
software that can't run on serverless
platforms but that said by and large
most scenarios are actually compatible
with serverless even those with special
requirements
and then there's the question of control
yeah some organizations don't go
serverless because they aren't yet
comfortable giving up control of the
machine yep it can be scary to give up
lower level management especially for
Mission critical workload right and many
organizations realize that serverless
can increase productivity for their
developers but they want to go slow so
they can learn the characteristics of
serverless before they adopt it
wholesale honestly that approach makes
sense to me me too I should mention that
you can ask your cloud provider to do
even more than Paz if you're using Gmail
for example you don't write the software
or figure out how to store the email
data Google does that for you and that's
called software as a service or SAS so
let's say I built a system for managing
expense reports it would look like
software as a service SAS to my
customers because all they do is enter
expenses they don't write software right
right and if you built your system on
cloud run or Cloud functions it looks
like platform as a service to you okay
so platform as a service for me exactly
what would I manage for platform as a
service you're responsible for the
application and the data for the data
that means taking backups and that sort
of thing yes and even if you're running
on top of a fault tolerant major cloud
provider you may still need backups and
restores you may have written an
application bug that destroyed some data
or a customer may accidentally delete an
expense report all things where your
application could cause a problem for
itself makes sense so I need to enable
backups exactly but it's not enough to
Simply enable backups you want to
rehearse the process for restoring a
backup if it doesn't work when you need
it it's useless okay that makes sense
you know me I've deleted not one but two
production databases as a startup I used
to work at thankfully we had backups
so when it comes to running my system on
serverless how would sres manage the
application the SRE team would monitor
that the application works as advertised
and is healthy for example they could
monitor a response times experienced by
users and the number of Errors displayed
to users and you mentioned things
visible to users you'd only monitor
things from the user's perspective no
but the user's perspective is very
important after all most service level
objectives or slos tend to be built
around the user's experience
yeah I've heard about slas or slos the
same great question no they're different
sres tend to use both of those terms
when talking about the goals for the
user experience an SLO describes a
realistic operational goal for the
uptime or user experience an SLA is
usually a business contract that
describes the consequences for violating
an SLL there's also a third metric in
this space service level indicator or
SLI I'm guessing that is the method used
for measuring the SLO exactly and SLI is
usually a metric used to determine if
you're meeting your SLO that makes sense
yeah the model tends to work really well
if you want to dive deeper on this topic
the free site reliability engineering
book at sre.google is a great resource
as well okay so we talked about making
sure we know if the user's experience is
degraded but what about preventing
outages in the first place
definitely there are some key metrics
you can use to infer and predict
application health and what do you
normally look at Mia I like to look at
the four golden signals latency traffic
saturation and errors okay and can you
walk us through what that would look
like in practice and on serverless
specifically definitely so let's start
with latency whether your application is
serverless or not keeping an eye on the
amount of time it takes to service a
request is crucial this helps identify
bottlenecks like database query latency
for example and a sudden spiking latency
could indicate an application issue as
well right yeah exactly the next metric
is traffic which describes the amount of
Demand on the system this can be helpful
for determining the individual container
also known as vertical resources for
your service right because Cloud run
will horizontally scale the number of
instances to match the traffic demand
but each individual container might need
more resources like memory
yep and I'm glad you mentioned
horizontal scaling because that's one of
the things that makes saturation less
important on serverless it's difficult
to saturate that's a win for serverless
in my book anything else people should
keep an eye on yeah I'd also say it's a
good idea to keep an eye on errors and
quotas like Max instances if you're
getting high numbers of failed requests
or an increase in error messages in
general it means something's not working
properly well thank you for explaining
all of this to us Mia I'm pretty much
convinced you need an operations team
and ideally an SRE team even if you've
gone serverless
definitely the reduced toil from going
serverless leaves more time for
important and interesting work that
helps map directly to the user
experience
thank you everyone for watching if you
have questions for me or me please
answer them in the comments below also
let me know if there are other
serverless topics you'd like to see in
future episodes we read every single
comment until next time
[Music]
thank you